okay so as we were talking about
yesterday on the ECT math livestream the
possibility of doing an SAT Math
livestream so that's what we're doing
here today there was a lot of requests
you know when's the next SAT math
livestream so I had some times I thought
I would jump on here again so what I
thought we could do is you know if
you're jumping onto the live stream just
introduce yourself kind of let let us
know where you're calling in from and
you know if you can ask questions you
know the more specific your question the
more that we can address that question
and help you but I think what I'll just
start off by saying is you know the SATs
you know it's been completely revised
and it's oftentimes referred to online
is the new SAT or the revised SAT and
basically you know the way the SAT is
set up is there's basically two sections
right there's a calculator section and
there's an on calculator section and
then amongst the calculator section
you've got a multiple-choice section as
well as a free response section and it's
the same thing with the you know the
calculator section there's a free
response and then there's also a you
know where you grid in and then there's
also a multiple-choice so it makes a
little bit more challenging because it's
not all just multiple-choice but if
you're just joining us can you let me
know can you hear me okay is the volume
okay are you able to to hear what I'm
saying if you could just comment and let
me know but yeah if you're just joining
us here what we're gonna do today the
plan is basically to do like a question
and answer session just regarding SAT
type questions SAT math questions so you
probably know me from my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring I've got hundreds
of videos on there so far talking about
all different aspects of math you know
algebra geometry trigonometry
precalculus as well as a CT and SAT
videos on there so but today we're
specifically focused on you know the SAT
math section so yeah so basically that's
the idea so if you're if you're just
joining us you know welcome and let me
know maybe if there's some questions you
have regarding the regarding the SAT is
there something that you want to talk
about specifically
you know right now I can see that people
are just starting to hop on but you know
go ahead and introduce yourself and you
know let me know if those are their
questions or things that you want to
discuss we can we can certainly do that
so yeah also want to let you know that
on my youtube channel you know if you're
looking for additional help you know
above and beyond what we're going to be
talking about today I've got some of the
worked out solutions to some of the SAT
tasks and I also have some other videos
just talking about some SAT concepts but
you know if you're just joining us here
now you know live introduce yourself
maybe let me know kind of what you what
you'd like to talk about if you have
some specific questions and you know we
can jump right into that and talk about
those so okay let's see so Kezia Oh says
I'm scared of the SAT because of that
math grid in section I like to stick to
multiple-choice well cuz yeah I'm right
there with you I that definitely is what
makes it more difficult you know is that
they kind of just leave it leave it a
completely up to you and you can put
that answer in that grid in section you
know either as a decimal or as a
fraction so yeah that's the thing you
know it is a little bit more challenging
because of that grid in you know they
just leave it up to you but yeah so cuz
you any questions anything you want to
ask me about any types of problems you
want to discuss maybe things that have
you taken the SAT already how did that
go if you did I know everyone's getting
you know ready for for the next test
coming up here you know not not too long
from now but most students are on summer
vacations so some students are taking
advantage of you know studying now and
yeah you know making the most of that
time to prepare ok so you've only taken
the acct so far how'd you do on the math
section of the AC t-- cuz yeah what did
you get on that section do you remember
any problems that really tripped you up
any any specific type of problems with
the AC t all you got an 18 on that
section okay so you definitely have some
room for you know improvement so that's
in that sense it's definitely good you
can definitely boost that score up from
there what math class are you in right
now are you in algebra 2 or your
geometry precalculus what
what level math are you in right now
because sometimes when students you know
they they take the a CT and s CT they
haven't reached you know some of the
statistics right now okay okay good so
there are some statistics problems on
there you know where they talk about the
mean the median the mode you know
standard deviation range that kind of
thing so that definitely that definitely
will help you but yeah I know sometimes
students they you want to take the SAT
but they haven't had all the math yet so
that definitely makes it a little bit
more challenging but what do you think
so are there any questions anything that
maybe I can help you with today I'm just
making myself available of course I've
got tons of videos on my Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel regarding the
SAT but in the AC T as well but I
thought I would jump on here live so
right now we've just got one or two
people but if you have specific
questions things you want to ask me we
can we can talk about it so I'm just
making myself available to to my my
viewers and also to some new people who
might have just just found me here
online so says I'm a senior I've taken
everything it's just I have trouble
retaining the information okay so that's
a good point cuz yeah well yeah
sometimes you know that's what makes a
little bit difficult is because it's
been a while since you've done geometry
or you've done you know Algebra one or
you know algebra two and that so what I
would recommend is have you gone to the
SAT College Board website where you can
download those free practice tests the
official practice tests that they've
released have you checked out those
resources yet I think right now up to up
to this point there is eight practice
tests on there and they've got you know
the answer keys and you know you can
take those tests and you can either do
them online or you can print them and
then you know just do them you know like
as you would you know in the real exam
scenario but if you haven't I would go
go over there and maybe download or do
the online tests there and start
practicing and the ones that you're
missing you know if you see a trend you
know if there's like maybe geometry
questions maybe you can focus more on
that section or algebra and so on but
that's probably the best way to get some
practice okay Mac is son okay welcome
back so I'm 25 and I'm practicing to
take the PSAT in tenth grade okay all
right so when you say 25 you mean you've
scored a 25 when you took the
or your or your what I didn't quite
catch that but okay but you're taking
the PSAT well you know the PSAT you know
/nm sqt as they sometimes call it you
know it's an opportunity where students
if they score really well they could get
scholarships and that kind of thing but
they're very similar the PSAT to the
actual SAT so definitely everything
we're going to talk about today you know
it can be applied to the PSAT or the SAT
so can can you guys and gals can you
hear me all right as my is a volume loud
enough can you can you hear me so this
is kind of a neat a unique opportunity I
mean we can talk about whatever you like
to talk about we can do any types of
problems you want to discuss if there's
things that oh y'all it's really quiet
okay Kezia says yup you're good okay all
right well okay so I hope the volume is
good enough you see if I can turn it up
on my end maybe it's okay so maybe
that's a little bit better but yeah so
what do you think so what types of
questions do you want to talk about
anything you want to discuss more
specific the better but I'll just kick
it off just to kind of get us going so
so say for example let me ask you a
question see I gave you an equation like
this say we had 3x minus 2y equals 12
okay Dario welcome Dario linear angles
in finding missing angles okay yeah we
can talk about that Dario yeah let's do
this question first and then we'll talk
about angles a little bit but yeah if
you're just joining us put some
questions in the chat and we can talk
about whatever you like to talk about
the more specific the better so I'm just
take kind of making up a problem here
just to kind of show you like a you know
potential type of problem that you might
encounter on the SAT so when you look at
these two lines
okay these are equations of lines how
would you find the solution of this
system so remember you know equation of
a line okay there's a line there is a
line right okay Dario more like Mario
okay got it all right so yeah so
basically we're trying to use we're
trying to find that point of
intersection of these two lines right so
any ideas anybody have some thoughts
about how we can solve the system I mean
there's of course the the graphing
method right there's the substitution
method
there's the elimination method or the
addition method however you want to call
that particular method there's matrices
there's a guess in check you know if you
have the solutions you can back
substitute but what do you think any
ideas on how we could solve this system
anybody want to jump in and give us an
idea how would you solve that system of
equations this is definitely something
that they test on that the SAT as well
as the acct really knowing how to solve
systems of equations so what do you
think what would you do first any ideas
well what do you think any idea so
basically okay if I was going to do this
problem what I would notice is that the
variables are lined up here on the left
the numbers are on the right so I would
probably think more along the terms
along the lines of elimination so I
would think to myself maybe I could
eliminate these X's for example right so
what I could do is take this top
equation multiply it by what negative 2
right so if I do that what does that
give us I'm gonna put the answer down
here that's negative 6x plus 4y equals
negative 24 okay
so now when we add these together what
happens well you can see that the X's
are cancelling out the Y's are
cancelling out so we're getting 0 equals
negative 6 so what does that tell us
when we get 0 equals negative 6
can anybody let me know about that what
do you think what does that tell us when
we get 0 equals negative 6 hmm what do
you think definitely doesn't make any
sense right if it was 0 equals 0 that
would make sense because that's always
true but 0 equals negative 6 that's
never true
ok Dario's saying no solution darío
you're absolutely right so yeah because
0 does not equal negative 6 that means
that there's no solution and the reason
that there's no solution is because if
you were to graph these two lines they
would actually be parallel ok and
they're not gonna they're not gonna
intersect they're not gonna cross now if
you got 0 equals 0 or 6 equals 6 you
know the same thing goes the same thing
then that's called an identity
okay meaning that the two equations are
identical and what happens is the two
lines are like basically they're
basically the same line so they're
crossing at an infinite number of points
so that would be an infinite number of
solutions or infinitely many so yeah so
these are some special scenarios that
you might come across when you're
solving systems of equations okay but
let's see so let's see somebody was
asking about basically lines and and
that type of thing like the angles and
that sort of thing so I'll just give you
some different scenarios like okay so
when you have a line and say we have
like maybe another ray coming off that
line like that what do you know about
these two angles right here do you
remember that from your geometry class
so when you have a straight line like
this right that's called a straight
angle and how many degrees are there in
a straight angle what do you think well
it's basically half a circle right so
yeah that's right cuz yeah it's 180
degrees so that means that these two
angles are gonna be yeah that's right
Dart 180 so that means these two angles
are supplementary
these are called a linear pair and these
two angles are gonna add up to 180 so
they may give you something like that on
the test where it's like maybe this
angle is 3 X plus 10 and maybe this
angle over here is like 4 X minus 20
something like that and then all you
have to do is just add these together
right and set them equal to 180 degrees
all right so if I'm doing this correctly
let's see what do we have here add the
10 to either side we get 190 divide
everything by 7 and you know that's
approximately what you would get here
let's see what that comes out to so
we've got 190 divided by 7 oops about 27
I'll just say it proximately 27 okay
yeah so other questions other things you
want to talk about we can talk about any
any type of SAT math question that you
want today the more specific the
question the more I'll be able to kind
of assist you and give you some better
ideas about how to work with those types
of problems what do you think where's
everybody basically from our woods do
so you guys from reading from from the
west coast East Coast where's everybody
from I'm here in Michigan okay Kesha is
from Florida and Dario's from Georgia
okay great okay good
yeah very good so we're more East
Coasters right we're on Eastern Standard
Time I know some people probably just
waking up over there on the west west
side of the country
but yeah so other questions you want to
talk about what other things would you
like to discuss ok Kezia and dairy are
neighbors yeah that's right
you guys could create your own little
study group over there that'd be that
would be cool so what do you think other
questions other things you want to talk
about so far we've talked about
basically systems of equations we talked
a little bit about angle measures right
what other things okay Dario is asking
what's a good book to study for the SAT
okay Dario that's a great question so as
far as books go okay the best thing to
do really
okay would be to go over to the SAT
College Board website and they've gotta
eat right so far I'm they keep adding
more each each each month or so they
have eight official practice tests okay
and they have the solutions there as
well and what you can do is you can
download those or you can even take the
tests online so that'll give you some
practice and you can kind of see which
problems that you know you're getting
stumped on and you're missing and you're
you forgot and so forth so I would go
over to that SAT college board site just
google it you'll be able to find it okay
Dario says yes I used Kant Academy with
College Board okay perfect yeah that's a
that's a very good resource aside from
that resource you know okay cuz he's
asking about the y-intercept okay yeah
we'll talk about y-intercept to the
other thing too is I'll I can let you
know about the course that I put
together for you guys and that's the
huge SAT math review video course I go
through 39 different concepts in that
video course it's all you know just with
me at the white board going through the
formulas and a teaching section and we
go through some practice problems
through 39 different concepts that are
tested on the math section of the SAT so
if you're interested in that I've got a
three
free lessons that you can check out to
see if you're interested and the link is
in the description of this video so if
you go to the link in the description
you'll see that and you can check those
out after after the live stream but yeah
so but basically okay so Kezia is asking
about the y y-intercept that's a very
good question Cassie because you know
what they are testing us on this
equation they want to make sure that
after you've taken all those math
classes in high school that that you
remember the y equals MX plus B form of
the equation of a line right so the M
stands for what and the B stands for
what well
the M is the slope right and the B is
the the y-intercept so they could very
well what they do oftentimes if you look
at the official practice test is they'll
give you an equation something like H is
the height equals 3y plus let's just say
it's like 48 okay and so it'll say this
is an equation for the height of
somebody Y after Y years okay so let's
just take that scenario I just mentioned
so this is an equation relates
somebody's height as a function of the
number of years so what do you think the
Kezia what do you think the 48 stands
for in this equation any idea what this
48 stands for so you were asking about
y-intercept so what do you think what is
that 48 stand for any ideas okay dar is
asking about how to graph linear
equations yeah we can talk about that
cuz he was saying equal to zero okay
yeah so basically when you talk about
the y intercept that's basically the
value when y is equal to zero because
you can see if you put zero and for y
the person's height would be 48 inches
right they'd be like four feet tall and
that's the key see when you when you
look at this equation the slope
intercept form of a line the B value
it's the y intercept but another way to
look at it when it comes to a story
problem is it's the initial condition
initial meaning like the starting
condition you know the this is the
height of the person at the start of
this time you know this time frame at
Year Zero right so then let me ask you
another question what do you think that
three
stands for and anybody can jump in on
this one what do you think the three
stands for in this equation hmm what do
you think well if we kind of look at the
right above here see it Y is kind of
like our h3 is like our m48 like our B
right so that M is three that means that
that's the slope but what does three
really represent well the slope is
another name for the slope especially
when it comes to story problems or word
problems what you want to remember here
is slope is the rate of change the rate
of change so what it means that this
person is growing by 3 inches per year
so if one year goes by now they're gonna
be yeah that's right cuz if for every
one increase it goes up 3 it goes up by
3 a shield a shield Barassi is this live
yes it is live so you're welcome to ask
questions we're talking about the SAT
the new SAT the math section so the more
detailed the question the more that I
can assist in that's what we're that's
what we're doing here right now so yeah
so welcome to the to the live stream but
Dario was asking about graphing so kind
of okay kind of just jumping on from
from this particular question like you
know you want to know how to graph lines
you want to know how to graph
inequalities and you really want to make
yourself familiar with this equation
okay Sheila saying can you do geometry
yeah we can do geometry but can you be a
little bit more specific about what
aspect of geometry even if you have a
specific problem or something you know
the more specific you can be the better
that can assist but Dario was asking
about you know graphing lines you know
graphing linear equations and so if you
can get it into this form diary where
you have that y equals 2x plus 1 you
know the y equals MX plus B you get that
Y by itself all you have to do is you
know go ahead and say alright here's my
x-axis here's my y-axis the B is the
y-intercept so that means it's crossing
here at one right and then the M the
number in front of the ax that's your
slope okay you can think of this as a
fraction by putting it over 1 remember
the slope is the rise over the run so
from this point I'm going to go to rise
to run 1 and you can repeat that process
rise to run 1 and so on
and that's how you get your line the
other way to do this and a lot of
students like this method is you can set
X to 0 and solve for the y-intercept and
set Y to 0 and solve for the x-intercept
once you find those two points then you
just graph your line through those two
points so I don't know does that help
you little bit more Dario's at kind of
what you're asking about so again
basically what we were talking about
here is just the slope intercept form of
the line and then up here we were
talking about how the slope refers to
the rate and the y-intercept refers to
the initial condition so if you're just
joining us on the live stream now we're
just doing a QA so anything you want to
ask me about or anything you want any
type of question the more specific you
can be the more that I can you know
address it a little bit better too to
help you get something more out of this
so yeah so the more you more you can put
in the more you can get out basically
right so what other things would you
like to talk about we've gots we've got
some some diehards with us Dario and
Cassio are asking a lot of good
questions and a sheíll I think is just
joining us asking us about geometry but
what do you think other questions other
things you want to talk about I'm happy
to happy to help you guys out any ways
that would be helpful what other kinds
of questions would you like to talk
about have you so has has anybody taken
the a CT at all or the PSAT have you
taken those tests at all do you remember
which ones were giving you trouble there
so you know yesterday I did a live
stream on the ECT talking about the ECT
and I'll just mention a question that I
I bring this question up all the time to
students because you know every point
counts right so I mean every question
that you get right that's an extra point
right so there's no reason why you
shouldn't try to capture every single
possible point and an easy question to
get right is this question right here
that involves you know the equation of a
circle right so I don't know if you've
ever seen this before but if you haven't
I would definitely memorize this the the
center of the circle is at H comma K and
R is equal to the radius of the circle
right so for example they give you a an
equation looks like this X minus 2
squared ok she was asking about complex
numbers ok that's that's more specific
yeah I can definitely we can definitely
talk about that together yeah so we can
definitely do that good good question
we'll do that one next ok and then the C
then this equals 16 so so let's see so
Kezia and Dario and she'll what do you
think
let's see argh and diagrams I'm not
familiar with argon diagrams maybe you
can tell me more about that I think that
you mean like Venn diagrams but let's
see so basically can you guys tell me
where's the center of this circle and
what's the radius so where's the center
of the circle and what's the radius hmm
it's a good good question huh
what do you think Oh Luke Cage is
joining us can you please solve a system
of linear equations oh you know what I
just did Lou if you just go back a
little bit to the beginning of this live
stream that was one of the first
questions we did so you can check that
out by a good question but yeah we
talked about linear equation systems but
so yeah so can anybody tell me so
where's the center of this circle and
what's the radius and then we're going
to talk about some complex numbers that
a she'll wanted to talk about what do
you think any thoughts no anybody's the
center of the circle radius of the
circle what do you think huh ah there we
go okay Kaz you seen two comma three
what do you think is that right the
radius is 16 is a shield right
Lucis Rhys is 16
well your your very close but okay okay
first of all see how this is R squared
let's see how that's the radius squared
we have to take the square root of 16 to
get the radius so the radius here is
actually just 4 right and then the
center is actually at positive 2 and
negative 3 ok now you're probably seeing
yourself a white positive 2 and why
negative 3 okay yeah Dario you're right
to negative 3 radius for C it's the
opposite sign see how it's X minus H X
minus 2 so it's actually a positive to
see Y minus K this is like Y minus a
negative 3 so what you can think of is
these actually have the opposite sign
say that's minus this is positive this
is positive this is negative the
opposite and you have to just make sure
to take the square root so then if you
wanted to graph that circle all you have
to do is go ahead and locate the center
so 2 negative 3 so be right there and if
the radius is 4 from this point you just
go up four down four right right 4 1 2 3
4 and left 4 right 3 4 so be rate and
that just kind of gives you some easy to
plot points and then you've got your
circle so if you're just joining us
we're just doing some SAT math QA
questions and answers so if you can ask
questions in the chat the more specific
the more that I can help you with that
and if you guys have questions for each
other you know go ahead and ask those in
the chat sometimes you know some of the
best some of the best benefits come from
the help that everyone provides to each
other but let's let's go to what a
shield was saying so she was asking
about complex numbers so what's a
complex number well a complex number is
a number that's ok Dara's asked about
how to solve quadratic equations ok
that's ok good question if we can do
that one next but let's talk about
complex numbers for a second and then
we'll get into the quadratic equation so
complex numbers you know what they are
they're they're part real and they're
part imaginary right so all together
that makes them complex so for example
if you had a number like 3 plus 2i yeah
that's right so B is the imaginary part
and the BI ok and then a is the real
part that's exactly right
so so a she'll you were asking about
these complex numbers
so maybe you can answer this question
anybody can answer it really but say if
I wanted to subtract this complex number
minus this complex number what would you
get for that one this is a common
question you know they want you to
understand complex numbers on the SCT so
definitely something important to talk
about so what do you think if you had to
subtract these what do you think you
would get what would the result be by
the way if you're real for real okay
good that's a good start yeah so what do
you think the final result would be
imaginary from imaginary okay that's a
good okay so what do you what do you get
what would the final answer would be
what would the result be here so you're
subtracting these two complex numbers
what do you think any thoughts on that
what what would the final answer being
hmm do we do distribution yeah Kezia
okay that's that's a good point you
could you could think of it as
distribution you can think of this as
like negative one here okay and you
could say well I'm gonna take this
negative one and distribute it right so
let's go ahead and do that so that would
be negative four okay she'll sing
negative one plus 5i okay let's
double-check his his or her work there
and see if that's correct okay so we
distributed following keshia's
suggestion okay now I'll get to do is
combine like terms so three plus
negative four is negative one two I plus
three is five I and you've got it so
that's that's exactly right so she'll
was right and let me ask you another
question about complex numbers does
everybody know what I squared equals
what does I squared equal anybody
remember that one this is important you
want to know what I square it is do you
remember anybody what do you think
remember I is what equal to what square
root of negative one okay Dario's saying
it's negative one and she'll sang root
negative one because you sing too and
Dario sing
question mark okay so let's see I is
equal to square root of negative one so
if I squared that means you're doing
square root of negative one okay man
sees joining us negative one yeah that's
exactly right so when you take the
square root of negative one times square
root of negative one you get negative
one so I'll show you another example
with complex numbers and then we're
gonna talk about quadratic equations a
little bit
that's what dargah was wondering about
so say for example we had the same
problem 3 plus 2i but instead of
subtracting we're multiplying these two
complex numbers so what do you think
what's 3 plus 2i times 4 minus 3i see if
you can calculate that one and if you're
thinking of other questions you want to
talk about put those in the chat and we
can definitely talk about those okay
Dario saying the foil method ok that's
that's good okay let's go with Dario's
method so remember foil is that acronym
it stands for first outer inner and last
right so the first terms means the first
term in this group times the first term
in this group that gives you 12 the O
stands for the outer ones the ones
towards the outside so that's three
times negative 3i which is negative 9i
the eye is for the inside those are ones
towards the middle or the center so
that's 4 times 2i which is a tie and
then the last means the last term in
this group times the last term in this
group so 2i times negative 3i is what
it's negative 6i squared because
remember I times I that's I squared it's
like x times X x squared so now let's go
back negative 9i plus 8i is negative 1 I
write this is 12 but now remember how we
said that ok good diary I combine like
terms I swear it as a negative 1 but
then times this negative 6 would
actually give us a positive 6 and then
like Darwin was saying we want to
combine like terms so that's going to
give us 18 minus I okay yeah she'll said
6 ok that's good and then so yeah then
you just want to combine the real
together and the imaginary together and
you always want to put it in that a plus
bi form the real first imaginary second
and then et minus I is your final result
so we did that subtracting complex
numbers here we did multiplying complex
numbers we talked about how I squared
equals negative 1 and we talked about
how I is equal to the square root of
negative 1 so that's kind of a little
good intro to complex numbers definitely
something important so if you're just
joining us but put your questions in the
chat and the more specific the question
the more that you know I can help assist
you with that and you know everyone
that's on the live stream can help you
as well so yeah so the better the more
questions you ask the more that the more
that I
and assists right okay but let's see I
think Daria was asking about quadratic
equations so what is a quadratic
equation does everybody know what a
quadratic equation is what does
quadratic mean it's a little confusing
because quad you know sounds like like
for right like quadriceps or something
like that but quadratic actually means
that it's in this form it's a second
degree equation like ax squared plus BX
plus C equals zero right so one of the
Dario one of the easiest ways to solve
quadratic equations is to get everything
on one side set it to zero and then of
course you can use the the infamous
quadratic formula right negative B plus
or minus the square root of b squared
minus 4ac all divided by 2a right that's
one way to do it another way to do it is
you could try to factor this
you know factor it and set the factors
equal to zero you know for example like
if I had x squared minus X minus 12
equals zero I could just say well hmm
let me let me factor this and then I
could set each group each factor equal
to zero right that's another option does
anybody know how to factor x squared
minus X minus 12 equals zero does
anybody know how to factor this left
side of the equation
okay Kezia saying can we do ratio and
probability next yeah definitely yeah
definitely we can definitely talk about
that if you have something more specific
that you know about that let me know but
yeah we can we can talk about that in a
general way but yeah if you're just
joining us on the live stream welcome
we're talking about not a CT but SAT
Math okay man see Joshi is saying X
minus four X plus three darío saying
find the multiples okay let's see X
minus four X plus three yes it's kind of
like doing the foil method backwards
right so you can see like first times
first gives us x squared okay that's
good and then last times last gives us
the negative twelve and then all we're
doing is checking at the inner product
and the outer product see negative 4x
and positive 3x add up to the middle
term negative 1x so that's exactly right
so then all you have to do now is you
just take this group X minus four and
you set it equal to zero and the same
thing over here you set X plus three
equal to zero
if you add four to both sides subtract
three from both sides those are your two
solutions for negative three right so
that's that's one way Dario to solve
these quadratic equations it's to see if
you can factor and then set the factors
to zero or if it's more difficult to
factor you can always do the quadratic
formula and that's another way to do it
you know there's also completing the
square there's graphing you know there's
a lot of different techniques but oh
okay Luis okay well Luis was with us on
yesterday's live stream so welcome
welcome back completing the square okay
so I guess we can talk about completing
the square before we go over to keshia's
question about the ratios and
probabilities and that kind of thing
okay let's see Dario's got one let me
see if I can yeah I like how specific
you guys are being so the more specific
you know the better I can the better I
can help you guys out you know I can
always try to make them up off the top
of my head which I'm pretty good at
doing but sometimes it's better if you
have something more specific okay so
you're wondering you're asking basically
how to solve this one Dario is that
right and Luis is asking about
completing the square okay so let's see
if we can maybe tackle this from a
couple different directions here one way
to do this is is to clear the
denominators okay so can anybody tell me
what the common denominator is of three
two and four what's the lowest common
multiple or the lowest common
denominator of three two and four
see if you can see if you can tell me
what that is what's 12 okay that's right
Dario so if we multiply everything by 12
okay good man ceases 12 also good
excellent so that gives us 8x squared
this gives us negative 6x and this gives
us let's see what is that negative 9
right okay good so now what we can do is
if we want to do the completing the
square method okay just to show you
another possibility is we can well we
could try to factor this we could try to
do the quadratic formula but if we want
to do the completing the square method
what's sometimes easier is to get this
leading coefficient equal to one okay so
what I'm gonna do here first is I'm
going to add the nine to the other side
just to get it out of the way
okay just to get it out of the way I'm
going to show you I'm trying to show you
kind of two techniques at once but then
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna divide
everything by eight so if I do that I
get x squared six divided by eight is
3/4 and then this of course is 9/8 right
okay so and this is kind of talut
release or Luiz Diaz this question so
how do you complete the square well what
you do is you take half of this middle
coefficient so what's half of 3/4
it's 3/8 and if you square that what's
3/8 squared
it's 9/64 right but if you add 9/64 to
the left side you have to add 960 force
to the right side because you want to
keep the equation balanced right so then
all you have to do now is you just have
to factor this but the way we've set it
up is we've set it up to be a perfect
square right let me multiply this by 8
over 8 which gives you 72 plus 9 which
is 81 64 and then over here we've got X
minus 3/8 now just a quick hint it's
always going to be half of this middle
coefficient when you do this completing
the square process so you take half the
middle coefficient you square it and you
add that to both sides but when you go
to factor it it's going to be half of
this middle coefficient so then Dario
and and Luis
all we have to do now see we're in the
homestretch is we just have to take the
square root ok the square root of both
sides and when you do that how many
answers do you get two right so that's
nine eight plus or minus right and then
the square and the square root cancel
here so we just get X minus 3/8 and all
we have to do now is add the 3/8 to both
sides to get X by itself
okay Kezia is asking a very specific
question about ratios okay what we're
going to do that one next CAHSEE okay
good good question so then what you want
to do here is just do two problems so
3/8 plus 9/8 is 12 eighths right so
that's one of our answers and three
eighths minus 9/8 is a negative six
eighths and you can just reduce those so
does that help with the completing the
square and solving quadratic equations
what do you think is that is that kind
of what you were looking for does that
help
so yeah so if you're enjoying this
livestream so far you know make sure to
give it a thumbs up so I know to do more
of these for you for you guys and gals
in the future and you know that's that's
great and then if you haven't subscribed
to the channel yet go ahead and
subscribe to the channel and you can
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and we're gonna do keshia's question
you're next talking about the ratios so
let's go ahead and talk about ratios
with Kezia so let's see and anybody can
answer these questions and think of
other questions you want to ask me about
too but let's see has you seen the ratio
of men to women is five to three right
if there are a total of 24 people in the
group okay how many women are there I
got this problem from the AC T book okay
okay
so this is a good question because you
see how it says it's five to three is
the ratio of men to women so I'm just
gonna put men two women but you know it
says there's 24 total people in the
group so instead of maybe setting it up
like this like men to women why don't we
do women which is three to the total
which is three and five
so 3 to 8 so now I'm goona ratio women
to the total okay and if there's 24 in
the group that's 24 down here and we
want to find out how many women there
are in the group so did you just see
what I did there cuz yeah I said 5 + 3
is 8 that gives us the total so the
ratio of women which is 3 to the total
equals the ratio of the number of women
to the total in the group 24 all you
have to do now is you can do this one of
two ways you can either say 8 times 3 is
24
that's right man see 3 10 yeah and then
3 times 3 equals 9 or if you don't like
that method you can cross multiply you
can say 8x equals 72 so you definitely
want to know how to cross multiply you
know and solve ratios and proportions or
you can do what I just did there
multiply the top by 3 in the bottom by 3
as long as you do the same thing to the
numerator and denominator
you guys are asking some great questions
it's very good the more you ask the more
that I can help you with that and I
don't know if I mentioned this yet but
I'll just mention it now if you're
preparing for the
you know the a CT or the SAT you know
the mass sections
check out my two video courses I have
one for the a CT and it goes through 65
different concepts it's about three and
a half hours of video you can have
lifetime access to that and then also
with the SAT I go through 39 concepts
you know covering the math section and
again lifetime access and you can go
over there I've got a link in the
description of this livestream so if you
go down there you can there's three free
lessons in each of these two courses so
maybe go ahead and go through those
three lessons first see if it's
something that you're interested in you
know you'll get some benefit out of
those and then if you want to go on and
do the entire course you can purchase
that so I definitely recommend these
both of these courses but if you're just
focusing on the SAT you might just want
to get this one or just the a CT might
just want to get this one but check
those out and yeah so that's that's the
idea there so just one second I had a
little technical difficulty let me see
here yeah oh wow okay there we go okay
so is everyone with me with that okay so
we're back had a little problem my cell
phone there for a second okay so what do
you think other questions other things
you want to talk about you guys are
asking some great questions you know
after this live stream you know go on
over to my Morrow's matthew dream
youtube channel if you want to get some
more help with the a CT and SAT I've got
a lot of videos talking about those
concepts but what other questions do you
want to talk about looking back through
the chat right now see what other things
were asked do another completing the
square for for Luis Diaz if he's still
with us just to kind of show you a
little bit more about that like so you
say for example if you had x squared
minus 4x let's just say plus 2 something
like that equals 0 right so if you
wanted to complete the square you know
the key is to get this constant to the
other side okay so you would subtract 2
from both sides so we've got x squared
minus 4x plus blank right and then all
you have to do now to complete the
square Luis is you just take half of
negative 4 which is negative 2 and then
you square
which is four so half of this middle
number squared so negative two squared
is four but you know if you add four out
of thin air to the left side you have to
add four to the right side because you
want to keep the equation balanced you
don't want to change you know the value
of the overall equation right then when
you factor this it works out to a
perfect square
see X minus two the quantity squared but
you set it up that way right so it's
always gonna be half of this middle
coefficient C half of negative four is
negative two but you can check it by
foiling this out once you get to this
point you're home free you just have to
take the square root of both sides so
you get plus or minus square root of 2
the square and the square root cancel
then you just have to add the two to the
other side so you get x equals two plus
or minus square root of two make sure
you put it in front of the plus or minus
sign that's the key okay so Dario's
asking about function notation okay
that's a good question yeah so function
notation yeah we can talk a little bit
about that so let's see so when you talk
about functions what are we talking
about well functions are basically
you've probably seen this in your math
class or if you haven't gotten this far
yet
you've got f of x equals let's just do a
simple example 2x minus 3 what do you
think F of 2 would equal so you
definitely wanna understand how
functions work for the SAT if you're
just joining us we're just doing a Q&A
so anything you want to ask you know the
more specific the question the better I
can assist you and you know we're just
going through some different concepts
and problems that you might want to know
for the SAT math section so yeah so
welcome to the welcome to the live
stream so can anybody tell me so what
would be the value of f of 2 so Luis
Diaz is saying 1 okay what do you think
is that right yeah that's exactly right
because okay so Daria remember
whatever's in the parentheses goes in
for X on the right side right so this is
going to be 2 times 2 minus 3 so that's
4 minus 3 which is 1 so that's the key
whatever's in the parenthesis goes in
place of X on the right so that's it so
I mean function notation is just a
different way of writing it but when you
see the f of X this this is really like
the Y value it's like the output you
know in the X whatever's in the
parenthesis that's like your input so
it's just a different way of writing the
equation instead of saying y equals MX
plus
or something like that they use f of X
so you could maybe name your function H
of X for the height or you know D of X
for for the distance something like that
you know it's like a more descriptive
way of writing the equation alright so
what do you think other questions other
things you want to talk about what other
I think somebody had another question on
here I might have I might have passed
over it let's see so what do you think
other questions you want to ask here's
your here's your chance you've got me
we've got a nice small group here so you
can definitely get your questions
answered so what else would you like to
talk about so if you're interested I'll
just mention if you're interested in
online tutoring with me for your math
class or for the AC T or the SCT I'm
also available for that if you're if
you're interested in getting some
private - online tutoring with me
usually during the school year I'm super
busy working with students in person but
sometimes I work with students online as
well if they're not you know in my local
area here so yeah so basically let's see
I did something happen to your technical
difficulties okay let me see okay here
we go so Lou Lou K is asking us let's
see if y equals KX where K is a constant
okay so let's write this down y equals
KX where K is a constant and y equals 24
when x equals 6 right what is the value
of y when X is equal to 5 okay so you
know what Lou K is asking us okay Lou's
asking us about direct variation
equations so this is like what they call
a y varies directly with X okay and K is
what's your constant a variation some
books use the letter A so y equals a
times X but the key here is they give us
a hint right they say well when y is 24
X is 6 so if we divide both sides by 6
it looks like a equals 4 right so then
you just have to put that 4 or back in
for a so now you've got y equals 4x now
we've got a more specific equation it
says well what does y equal when X
equals five well let's put 5 in for X
now and you get 4 times 5 so y equals 20
so basically Lou I don't know if that
helps you a little bit better but
basically you start off with your direct
variation equation y varies directly
with X they give you this information
over here to kind of help you to solve
for that constant of variation ok then
once you have that more specific
equation you can put 5 in for X and you
can solve for y so yes a good question
direct variation equations you know
something important to understand for
the for the math section of the SAT so
yeah great great question so other
questions what do you think other things
you want to talk about so is everybody a
subscriber to my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel have you guys found out
about me through through the through the
YouTube channel or did you just stumble
on on this online or how did you how'd
you find me through my channel yeah so
pretty much I've been uploading videos
you know on a regular basis probably
averaging about one a week or so so
there's new videos coming out all the
time you can check that out and you can
also search on my youtube channel for
specific concepts for for your math
class ok man see saying through your
channel okay great and Lewis says Dario
asked about graphing yeah yeah good
question so Dario asks about graphing oh
because he's a subscriber okay great but
let's see somebody asks a specific
question because he is he asking about
geometry question line M passes through
the point 4 3 and a standard XY
coordinate plane and is perpendicular to
the line described by the equation y
equals negative 4/5 X plus 6 which of
the following describes line M well here
let's just talk about this so see if the
equation is y equals negative 4/5 X plus
6 and it passes through the point 4 3
and it's perpendicular so let me ask you
a question because yet what's the slope
of the line that's perpendicular Oh
Daria you're asking about graphing
functions well I'm sorry Daria we'll
come back to that one after this
question we'll talk about graphing
functions okay thanks Luis for for
double-checking with me ok that's great
so yeah we'll go back we'll talk about
graphing functions so basically okay
equals negative 4/5 X plus six so what's
the slope of the line that's
perpendicular meaning at a right angle
to this line
can anybody does anybody know what the
slope of that perpendicular line is so
what do you what do you know about the
slopes of parallel lines and what do you
know about the slopes of perpendicular
lines
uh-oh what do you guys think what's the
slope of the perpendicular line to this
line okay five four so okay good so
that's exactly right so
tazzy is answering that one yeah that's
right so what you want to do is want to
take the opposite reciprocal so you take
the opposite sign okay yep Mansi says is
negative reciprocal Lu says that okay
they're equal if they're parallel that's
right if they're parallel they are equal
but if they're perpendicular they're
opposite reciprocals so what we have now
is y equals five force ax plus B so this
is a six over here this is a B over here
but Kezia if it goes to the point four
three they're giving you a hint so you
put 4 in for X 3 in for Y and then you
solve for B so let's go ahead and do
that real quick we got 3 equals 5/4
times 4 over 1 the fours cancel right
that's just 5 we subtract 5 from both
sides that means B equals a negative 2
and you put negative 2 back in and
you've got it so it's y equals 5/4 X
minus 2 now okay to kind of you know
basically merge with the with dario's
question about graphing function see y
equals 5/4 X minus 2 is a function it's
just not written in the function
notation so for example instead of
writing as Y I could write this as f of
X equals 5/4 X minus 2 and then we could
graph that function is that what you
mean by graphing functions
darío is that what you're asking about
is how to graph something like this well
if we were going to graph this you can
see it's just the y-intercepts negative
2 so we go down 2 on the y-axis and then
the 5 force is a slope and remember
slope is rise over runs from here we're
gonna go rise 1 2 3 4 5 & a run 1 2 3 4
so rise font 5 run 5
or and then all you have to do is you
know get out your straight edge and draw
a line through those two points so it's
really just like graphing lines you know
like in this particular case is just a
line but here I've written it in
function notation the f of X notation so
graphing functions is you know it
depends you know whether it's a
quadratic function our linear function
you know cubic function polynomial
function like it depends on the
particular graph but they're the
functions you know there's all different
kinds of functions like some functions
that you should probably just kind of
know are like the absolute value
function like this guy here right of
course the quadratic function which is
uh the parabola like this square root
function this is an important one so it
looks like this right so you might want
to review you know these these graphs
you know and and how these graphs look
and how to graph them so yeah so good
good questions everybody's asking some
really good questions so what do you
think other other things you want to ask
me other things you want to talk about
for the SAT the math section what do you
think anything else you want to discuss
in more detail could you do probability
oh yeah I think somebody asked about
that earlier I completely forgot okay
yeah go use that good question so so
does anybody know like what's the
definition of probability so I mean they
want you know on the SAT they don't get
too deep into probability but they'll
ask you some some basic probability
questions so what's the definition of
probability any ideas what is
probability well we know probability is
like the chance that something can
happen the likelihood that something
could happen you know what's the
probability of rain today you know that
kind of thing but you know strictly
speaking you know probability you could
think of it as the number of successful
outcomes right the number of successes
divided by the total possible outcomes
so I'll just say total outcomes total
possible outcomes so a super simple
example okay just super simple example
see you have a hat and in the Hat
there's two red marbles and
one blue marble